i was thinking about the movie the
guilty which i i thoroughly enjoyed this
movie when you see it it's all jake
sorry about that by the way
no i'm saying it's like you're talking
on the phone to people and stuff and
you're a 9-1-1 operator you really get
to shine in this film well i mean just
like shouting out to like the 911
dispatchers across the country in the
world i mean that job is
just incredibly insane i mean
to think that like very often they don't
get to hear the end of the call
they're helping someone through some of
the hardest times in their life and then
they don't even know what happens
they'll spend an hour a minute a couple
seconds and someone in dire need you're
dealing with people on the worst day of
their lives and then you don't get to
know what happens and oftentimes they're
the unsung heroes in that space but as a
i think also the movies about mental
health you know like
i mean all yes you're dealing with
mental health the other people on the
line and our assumptions of what people
look like when we could just hear their
voice what our prejudices are what our
projections are all that stuff right but
also the mental health of the person
who's answering that call
that's right i mean the person who has
to get there and do that i mean so many
of our systems are so broken in dealing
with not just
not just the people who need help but
not looking at the people who are
helping who also need help and all these
stigmas around that space
and so i think like that's why antoine
and i wanted to make the movie on
another level outside of just being a
thriller and there being twists and
turns and stuff we knew would be
entertaining it was always the
discussion from the beginning which is
that this is a movie about all of us
and how broken our systems are and how
much we project on other people and the
mistakes we make as a result of that
like who the hell is answering the 9-1-1
call and what's their psychological
situation and i mean there's a first
line in it where he's like
there's a kid who calls and he says you
know he's like did you do drugs
he's like yes he's like
um you shouldn't do that you know
clearly he's not a guy very helpful
right yeah very very very healthy yeah
no toxicity at all in that comment but
like that's at the heart of it you see a
man
dealing with the idea i think of also
like masculinity and and and and how do
you how do you how do you help right how
do you help when you need help
and don't know you need help
and want to help that's the other thing
want to help but don't know probably
that you're not fully capable of being
there for someone else because you
haven't faced your own [ __ ]